so there's going to be a moment if
bitcoin continues to grow in its impact
when governments are going to seriously
contend with you know what do we do with
this
do you think about those moments is uh
bitcoin
is the cryptocurrency world in general
going to be able to withstand
the
serious legal pushback from countries
from nations especially authoritarian
nations yeah so it's been interesting
it's been
12 years okay more than 12 years since
satoshi nakamoto created bitcoin
and they haven't been able to stop it
they have tried they've tried a lot i
wrote a long essay for quill out on this
like like why haven't governments been
able to stop bitcoin and my thesis is
essentially that there's been like this
mix of different kind of technical
social uh and economic and political
incentives and disincentives that make
it very difficult
um and i think to me the the the best
way to think about it is that bitcoin's
like a trojan horse so just just to
actually
tell that story just a little bit
because i think it's important to
understand the classical mythology tale
um i find this very interesting of the
actual
actually by by virgil right and the idea
was the greeks had been like trying to
take the city of troy for like a decade
at these like impregnable walls and they
couldn't do it and ulysses and the rest
of the greek army were like we don't
know what to do um so minerva the the
the god of strategy and war you know
kind of like to get this idea from her i
guess to to actually try to use
subterfuge and trickery to take over the
city so the idea is and this was sort of
hatched by ulysses right to put this
horse together that would kind of be
like a gift so the idea was the greeks
just like pretended to leave right they
they deserted they left behind one
soldier and this horse and the trojans
looked at it and they were like what's
going on here and they brought in the
soldier and the soldiers like look they
left they're so sorry for all of the
desecration and blood spill this is
their gift to you it's you know honoring
minerva you know it's like this like you
know trophy for you guys and there were
actually people inside troy uh cassandra
a prophet as well as lao quan who was
like a priest who said no no this is
obviously a trick this is obviously a
trick um but they were like dispatched
and ignored because the horse was like
it was just like so badass so that the
trojans were like
bringing it in the city so they brought
it in themselves no blood spilled at all
right in the middle of the night of
course what you realize is the horse was
packed with greek soldiers and they come
out and they let the army in which was
like hiding behind an island so this
idea that like something could be so
attractive that you really can't say no
even if you know what's inside of it is
it played with in bitcoin so like
in bitcoin has this number go up
technology right is what we call it in
sort of shorthand ngo ngu right but what
people don't realize is that ngu is like
the trojan horse inside the trojan horse
is fgu freedom go up technology so
dictators and rogue regimes and
corporations are going to buy mine tax
accumulate this thing because it's the
best performing financial asset in the
world what they don't realize or
they're going to have to ignore is that
they're also aiding and abetting this
freedom technology which allows
individuals to be sovereign and
eventually erodes their power there's no
question that rogue regimes and bad
actors are already used and will
continue to use bitcoin the thing is
when you think about a north korea or a
venezuela
and that government instructs some of
its bureaucrats and cronies and
officials to start stealing bitcoin or
accumulating it or whatever
for short-term gain to get around
sanctions and and use it to buy dollars
or something like that right which they
can't get normally well guess what all
those people who the regime has
instructed to like figure this thing out
and use it they're all going to realize
oh my god this is money the government
doesn't control and it's going to spread
like a virus okay so this is like the
idea of the trojan horse allegory i
think it's so important and powerful
with bitcoin all the people talking
about bitcoin today on tv they don't
care about freedom or privacy they just
care about number go up but what they
don't realize is what's concealed within
and that's very very powerful to me
so the people talking about bitcoin and
tv are maybe investor types professional
investors
corporations and soon governments i mean
you just had today this morning on cnbc
the
leader of the uh the republican leader
of the house of representatives a
congressman saying like we need to be
pro bitcoin as a country and the other
day peter thiel had a very interesting
comment where he was basically like
let's not fall behind china in this race
so you have
influential people in our government
like sort of posturing for this like
you know bitcoin race that's going to
happen in the next 10 years you're going
to see this countries are going to
compete to stack bitcoin
absolutely so you believe the the thing
that's
shiny and sexy like the trojan horse the
number go up
too hard to ignore
and for to uh
to define that a little further meaning
it's it does seem like the more people
get excited and start using bitcoin the
more of its value grows so it's just a
good feedback loop yeah it's a feedback
loop and then the reason you're excited
about it especially is is that uh f g g
freedom go up freedom go up
which is it uh ultimately gives power to
the individuals to just so decentralized
yeah i mean like when tesla stacks
bitcoin
they're just doing that as self-interest
they think it's going to be a good
inflation hedge fund but what they maybe
don't care about don't realize or they
don't need to care i mean bitcoin's
power is it like co-opts people
into promoting a freedom tool even if
they don't care about or even if they
hate freedom it doesn't matter so when
tesla stacks bitcoin and the price goes
up and more interest goes up and more
people around the world are like wow
bitcoin then more people get involved
again more adoption more price more
developers better user interface more
privacy tools more mining more network
security it's just this like positive
feedback loop that continues to grow and
it will it will grow intensely in the
next decade as we go through the
adoption cycle and the reason why i'm so
excited about this is the human rights
world again to get back to our previous
conversation
it is very hard to find people who who
have you know the empathy
or the altruism to actually make a
difference abroad in places like china
or saudi arabia or north korea
people are very quick to just like
they'll just quickly
toss off the pretty words that they care
about human rights as soon as profits
come into play so there's no alignment
of incentives right the reason why
bitcoin is so powerful is that it aligns
the incentives all of a sudden they can
be as greedy as they want they are being
forced to promote a freedom tool this
i've never seen before and it makes me
it gives me a lot of like excitement
it's very refreshing because we've been
laboring in the human rights space you
have to like raise money and it's all
like nonprofit work and you're like
begging for people to make a difference
for you here you have this like
incredible asset which people will
accumulate out of self-preservation
self-interest and greed and yet it will
strengthen the power of the individual
that is what we need to fight big
brother that's what we need to fight
like what i'm scared is happening in
china like this growing authoritarian
state which is powered by big data
analysis
this is our way to fight back and and it
runs on this like
really interesting engine again that
like takes advantage of our base nature
as humans and i know that it sounds
terrible for me to say this but i mean
ultimately we are self-interested
and it is hard to to get people to care
about others living a thousand miles
away you know we are kind of
localized in our empathy
speaking as someone who works to help
people who live in
like 100 different countries it's very
difficult to get americans to care about
what's happening in belarus or in
kashmir it just is but guess what
they're going to definitely care about
bitcoin because they want to see their
their net worth go up they want to do
better for their family etc they're
going to get into this thing
and it's really going to like make that
powerful tool for everyone else who's
using it so this interplay dynamic is
fascinating to me
yeah i have to um so i'm somebody who
doesn't like
there are corrupting effects of greed
but it is also human nature
yeah i don't like it either but it we
have to be realistic you have to
acknowledge it and then maybe use it
for your advantage and it's not just
bitcoin itself like exchanges today are
adopting something called lightning
network which is a way to scale bitcoin
on a second layer much like we had gold
bars which we scaled with paper money
and then we had visa credit cards which
were a way of scaling the paper notes
bitcoin scales through lightning network
it's a private instant globally final
settlement network it's something you
all should
check out it's very very interesting
the exchanges aren't adopting lightning
for its privacy benefits like lightning
operates off the chain meaning
surveillance companies can't see they
can't do chain analysis on lightning
because it's it's on an onion routed
second layer kind of that works kind of
like the
into our project
the exchanges don't care about privacy
they're doing it because it reduces fees
lightning is cheaper and faster so again
we have this really interesting
alignment of incentives where like the
freedom tech is being promoted by people
who don't i don't it doesn't matter what
their incentives are i could care less
if they were altruistic or not
and i think this is
and you're going to maybe see this even
in the future there's more things coming
in bitcoin down the pike
lightning was enabled by an upgrade
called segwit right which took place a
few years ago which was the culmination
of the block size conflict
there's another thing coming up called
cross input signature aggregation which
may if it takes effect in the next few
years
it may compel exchanges to
collaboratively spend all their bitcoin
together in a way that really protects
our privacy and fights surveillance
but they're not going to do it for for
moral reasons they're going to do it
because it's going to save them money
and improve their bottom line can you
speak to that kind of collaborative so
you can have multiple parties in a
single transaction kind of thing yeah
like
you could do that today absolutely it's
called the coinjoin for example but
right now it's more expensive to
coinjoin a bitcoin you have to pay a
premium for your privacy
this would flip that on its head and
would basically say if you have one
transaction hey pile them all in have as
many parties as you want the more
parties you get in the cheaper it's
going to be per party okay and and
that's not possible in bitcoin today but
it might be in the future but again the
beauty the beauty in bitcoin are these
like
these ways that it just aligns human
incentives and it aligns our like most
base desires and needs
and realities
with like freedom and privacy and that
i've never seen before and that's why i
think it's so interesting
you